Chairs.
Chairs are made so that people can sit down and take a break.
Anyone can sit on a chair, and if the chair is large enough, they can sit down together...
...and tell jokes,...
...or make up stories...
...or just listen.
Chairs are for people,...
...and that is why chairs are like Facebook.
Doorbells,...
...airplanes,...
...bridges;...
...these are things people use to get together...
...so they can open up and connect about ideas and music and other things that people share.
Dance floors,...
...basketball,...
...a great nation;...
...a great nation is something people build so they can have a place where they belong.
The universe.
It is vast and dark,...
...and makes us wonder if we are alone,...
...so maybe the reason we make all of these things is to remind ourselves that we are not.